obtenir un grand ensemble qui est mieux
pour les mêmes objectifs le président du
conseil d'administration de Hockey
Canada Michael prenamour quitte son
poste selon lui il est inutile
d'attendre avant d'entamer une nouvelle
ère il écrit il était essentiel d'agir
immédiatement pour élever les défis
importants auxquels notre organisation
et notre sport sont confrontés et pour
lesquels notre plan d'action a été mis
en place le président sortant qui est
aussi avocat ne parle toutefois pas de
la responsabilité du conseil
d'administration dans le scandale il ne
présente aucune excuse ce qui dérange le
co-fondateur de l'organisme B210
là mais il y a des mécanismes qui ont
été mis en place par des gens qui sont
payés par l'organisme l'organisation je
veux savoir c'est qui et je suis certain
que les Canadiens veulent savoir ce qui
est eux doivent être imputables de leurs
gestes peut-être que ce sont des
vedettes le député Sébastien Lemire qui
a pu questionner les dirigeants de
Hockey Canada en comité juste au départ
insuffisant est-ce qu'on peut tirer le
plastrer une bonne fois pour toute puis
pour pouvoir faire le ménage qui est
attendu par l'ensemble de la méditation
lorsque ça prend maintenant c'est des
gens qui sont dans la pédagogie qui sont
dans l'éducation notamment au niveau des
de la santé de la sécurité sexuelle ça
va prendre des gens qui ont une
connaissance très diversifiée du monde
du hockey ça prend plus de femmes aussi
au conseil d'administration le ministre
des Sports parce que Saintonge à répéter
qu'elle demandait un changement de
culture profond à Hockey Canada mais
avec cette démission je pense qu'on
commence à voir des fissures dans la
forteresse et c'est comme ça que la
lumière peut rentrer le conseil
d'administration de Hockey Canada se
réunira cours des prochains jours pour
nommer son nouveau président intérimaire
pendant ce temps mardi le championnat
mondial de hockey junior débutera
edmunton dans un climat de crise pour la
Fédération et pour son président Scott
Smith qui lui tient à rester en poste
ici Antoine Radio-Canada Montréal